hey folks i'm current davina and welcome
to this special interview of play for
all joining me today is morgan
day the lead game designer of world of
warcraft's
shadowlands morgan welcome glad you're
here
thanks kurt awesome to be here so before
we jump into it
give me the elevator pitch what is
shadowlands what are we expecting
uh to be added into the world of
warcraft so
the shadowlands is you know it's it's
the place where you're sent
in one of the many potential afterlives
of azeroth as we've seen with the events
of battle for azeroth
sylvanas has has gotten her hands on the
helm of domination
and destroyed it and in doing so she's
ripped open
a tear in the sky which has created this
connection between azeroth and the
shadow lands
and effectively she has broken the
machine of death
and everyone is going straight to the
mall which is where the place where
normally only the worst of the worst
have
are sent so you know as we level up and
experience the shadow lands we're really
working to kind of fix
that machine of death and find out what
happened how did this happen and how do
we put it back together
i was able to play it just a little
briefly today
and i gotta say it is so grim and so
spooky
that it gives it gives me the ability to
see world of warcraft
very deliberately placed in this this
spooky afterlife
so what is that like being able to from
your perspective as a lead game designer
how are you honing in to that that kind
of more
this more macabre side of what we're
seeing and wow
totally so you know like like i was
talking about there's
potentially many different afterlifes in
the shadow lands there's
the place that you probably had a chance
to experience which was revendrath
so rev and draft is where those who are
just full of
um too much pride and sin and this is
almost like
basically the last stop before you get
into the maw and you're actually just
irredeemable right so this is where
you're sent
um to be removed of that sin but there's
also places where
people who have had valorous lives were
sent like the kirian
in in bastion that's a place where it's
it's beautiful it's idyllic it's you
know the golden castles in the sky
it's the you know the golden landscapes
where you know some
famous characters that you maybe haven't
seen in warcraft history like uther
you learn a lot about him and and oh you
find out that he might be there and what
is his story
so there's all kinds of different
opportunities to see
different landscapes and experiences and
certainly some are more macabre but
if that's not you know something that is
exciting or interesting to you
you know once you've leveled up one of
our major features is
something called um the covenant
sanctums or covenants where
you actually kind of get to choose hey
this is the sanctum that speaks to me
so speaking of covenants it feels very
deliberate it kind of in
breaking these molds and taking wow into
a different direction right now
uh in ways that maybe at first i thought
not in a bad way but a little jarring
like in an exciting way that it felt
like there was a push
to try and make this something else what
is kind of that process like
um in in trying to push players into
directions in which
uh we may not be used to like joining
these covenants and kind of
almost like factions uh factions within
existing factions that kind of in a way
horde alliance stuff like that yeah
speaking to the process of that you know
we're always inspired by the story that
we're trying to tell the fantasy of the
spaces that we're we're going to be
visiting
and often that story leads us into the
design direction that we
might want to pursue so with the
shadowlands in particular
you know we're we really love the rpg
roots you know that mmorpg
stems from where it's role-playing game
you know you you have character creation
and you
have all these choices that you're able
to express yourself and be
you know this is my character this is
where i'm playing through the game how
do we kind of
um really look revisit that and double
down on some of those
rpg elements so when we looked at shadow
lands we looked for those opportunities
and saw you know this this thing right
in front of us with these these
covenants
of you know these have different very
meaningful and different impact
and um you know um
themes that will speak to hopefully a
very wide audience from like we talked
about revenge
which is more macabre and kirian which
is more idyllic
there's also the knight fae in arden
wheeled which um
is more about the cycle of life and they
have these huge amazing
almost celestial looking trees in the
zone where you know if you're a druid
that might really speak to you
and finally there's maldraxis which is
the military
arm of the lands these are the these are
the people that would normally be
defending them from potential outside
invasions or people
and these are all very unique aesthetics
as well as stories that are
are there to be told that we want you to
feel invested in when you make that
choice
i'm certainly a druid dude myself so i
will go where
where the trees live and walk but uh
but given that am i as a player going to
be able to go
to join several covenants am i going to
be able to see these
plot lines if that's what if they're
considered through and from
these different kind of angles in this
new world of shadow lands totally yeah
so
that's something that we have you know
put a lot of thought into
from the onset of this expansion and
one of the things that we're really
excited about is you know
as you level through the shadowlands
we're actually doing a little bit of
best of both worlds where if you're
if you're um familiar with like battle
for azeroth or legion before shuttle
lands
the level up experience was was very
non-linear you could choose the zone you
want to
go to but from a storytelling
perspective that presented unique
challenges where we were like well what
if you're coming from here or here
here and it's more linear but as you
play through
additional times we wanted to give you
that freedom to maybe
go to the different zones in different
orders so once you've hit max level
if you make a new character because like
you said maybe you want to check out
um a different covenant this time you'll
actually be able to quest in
a non-linear fashion as well as earn
progress that's cool towards that
covenant
um even when you're not at max level yet
right i mean and that's and it's good to
know that there is some sense
of consequence um in some ways that make
it
like you said kind of a callback to
maybe the the more traditional
uh roots of of rpg development and
that's
honestly great to see in something like
an mmo and especially world of warcraft
again
one thing uh when it comes to like
dungeons and raids and some of the new
stuff we'll be seeing in shadow lands i
you mentioned it earlier but the maw uh
the way it's kind of described as this
is the sandbox where
you're not welcome what is that going to
be like for a player
and how will you how are you designing a
i guess a dungeon in a sandbox area
totally so um the maw itself will be
um more traditionally considered like an
outdoor zone
that you would have seen in world war
craft before where there's lots of
people running around
and within the mall there isn't a
dungeon but there is tour guest
tower of the dam which is one of our
major features of the shadowlands
which is um very much so inspired by
uh almost rogue light or roguelike games
where
every play through you're earning new
powers there's different
things that you're um gaining to make
that run
feel very different and unique and the
power increase that you're going to gain
in that individual
run of tour guests is far greater than
what you would see in
a standard dungeon right but it's unique
in that you can't take those powers out
those those stay there and if you
once you've completed the run and you
you you want to do another one you start
over and you start to pick new powers
and
tour guest is where um the the seat of
power for the jailer is who is you know
the big bad he's the villain that um as
we've learned sylvanas has been
working with this character all along
and a lot of our story
lines of battle for azeroth kind of ties
into the shadow lands and we learn in
the mall oh this is where
this guy has been the maw itself like
like we've talked about is very much so
a zone that is more sandboxy
it's a lot more discovered content there
won't be as much
um directed content like there won't be
tons of world quests all over the place
so uh in in many ways the the many many
ways you've been subverting
uh kind of what i would consider fan
expectations
in all this is you're you're changing
the level cap from
120 and now people are gonna be if you
if you're at the
max level cap you're gonna be squished
to level 50.
what was kind of the design choice and
what was the like the the process in
deciding
how you approach something like that
especially maybe for a player that has
worked to a certain point and now
suddenly feels like they're back down
what's in a number anyways but i want to
hear what you think about that
you know this is something that we've
actually gotten a ton of feedback from
our community for a long time about you
know people love to try
new classes new characters and they want
to level up new
level up to play with their friends in
you know battle for azeroth or whatever
in this case shadow lands and just the
period of time it takes to do that
to just actually level up was starting
to get a lot of feedback that hey this
is taking a while
so we really wanted to look at this as
an opportunity to kind of revisit that
feedback
our new target through shadow lands when
in order to level from level 1
to level 50 which is when you'll be able
to enter the shadow lens is much closer
to like
a you know 15 20 hour range where
previously it was
you know many times longer than that
we've also taken this opportunity to um
you know look at
creating a new um new player experience
that is
um really epic and awesome and tells a
story that feels very warcraft with
um we created a new starting experience
called exiles reach where
both horde and alliance when they create
new characters will go to exile's reach
and they'll
level up through this island where
there's lots of mischief
and um stories to unfold that feel very
core to warcraft
there are class quests that you might
experience as you progress through that
and it and it finally ends off with a a
little
mini dungeon which felt like we were
trying to really express
all that world of warcraft had to offer
in this experience
and once you come out of there um you
know you're not far off from being able
to play
with all your friends at max level going
off of that or at least you know
going out of ways so we talked about the
mall we talked about covenants
and also you know squishing
these little caps to try and make your
game uh new and fresh for new people and
it sounds like you're you're really
making an effort to try and make the
game
have some longevity which clearly it has
already what is you know are these the
core things that you think
are gonna keep it going for as long as
the world of warcraft will turn
that's a great question that's actually
a very
hard to answer question too i think you
know one of the things that we
are most thankful for and the things
that were you know
just excited is having such a passionate
and engaged
community that has gone through this
experience with all of us
um you know we ourselves on the world of
warcraft
development team were huge fans of the
game ourself
you know we love to play i in the before
times when i could go into the office
it was very common on you know monday
morning that for people just be
kind of walking around the office and
and sharing their experiences and giving
feedback and be like oh did you
check out the new thing last night like
oh that was way too hard we should nerf
it right like
and and that you know that having that
community and
as well as the development team that
shares the passion for the game is
something that has
really kept us moving forward and and
growing as a as a game and that's just
something that you know we all feel very
fortunate to be able to work on this
and and experience it with our players
at the same time
uh going back to creating new things
trying to make things engaging exciting
we
there's also the theater of pain which
is a phenomenal title yeah totally so
the theater pain is one of our max level
dungeons
um this is actually our only
five boss dungeons so it's quite a it's
a little bit longer and a bit more epic
experience than some of the level up
dungeons and in the theater paint itself
um you know this is this takes place in
maltrax's which like i said it's very
you know
mine is right and super metal and
they're all about you know just
combat so the story there is when you
show up there's this trial
this this trial of champions almost as
it were going
that's about to take place and the very
first thing you do is basically prove
that
you are the one that is worthy to go
into this trial to go into the theater
and after you defeat that first trial
you are sent down into
the theater where there is
representatives champions of the word
from each of the different houses of
maldraxis there's the warlords who have
their champion who
you know in his encounter it's one of
the things we've heard a ton of fun
feedback on i'm excited people get their
hands on where he actually sends two
players into a dueling pit
where even though we're party members we
have to duel each other
and whoever wins gets this huge buff um
you know there's the lich house where
there's actually a bit of a
i don't want to call it a puzzle but
there's a bit of an experience to even
get to
the lich who is the champion of the lich
house
that you're progressing through
different platforms and trying to go
through these portals to even get to him
it's almost you know maze-like um and
once you've defeated
him those two and the last one who's the
abomination which
they're very much about like um you know
patchworks that are stitching together
pieces
of of different creatures to create you
know the most powerful being
and then once you finally kind of come
out of that trial those three bosses
um once you've been victorious you go
back up and
basically fight the final trial which is
the undefeated
champion of the theater who's never been
defeated and
you do that in in this massive coliseum
with tons of people
watching you cheering you on as you guys
fight to the death
it's a really fun experience that's i
mean unfortunately we're running low on
time but
the things i want to touch back on is
that this game is spooky or at least
what i saw was it was grim
we have the theater of pain this which
sounds so metal
and then uh it's really cool to hear
about the covenants and things like that
and
and personally i've walked away really
by the idea that it feels like there's
a lot there to like i've mentioned many
times to avert fans
um into something different but also new
that's sad
right as we as friends we walk out of
this what is the key like the
the small very thing you can say to any
player who's been hesitant to get into
wow and why now
should be that yeah um you know we
talked about this a little bit earlier
but there's been
tons of um features and new things that
we're trying to introduce with
you know the lower level cap and the
level squish as as you called it
and the new player experience that has
true you know
really we feel like more modern
tutorialization to kind of get you into
an understanding
you know maybe you've never played an
mmo before and you don't understand like
what's all the rage about like
the exiles reach is an opportunity to um
provide that with with provide that
experience to players
i haven't seen that before you know that
that multiplayer element of this people
all around me and we're solving this
mystery together
um and all of those things combined i
feel like it's
it's really one of the best times to get
into world of warcraft if it's always
felt a little bit too intimidating or
like there was
too much of a barrier between you and
trying it for the first time or really
trying
uh to make an effort to to lower or
remove as many of those barriers as
possible
fantastic all right before we walk off
morgan thank you so much for being here
uh the game's going in the beta next
week correct
do we have any plans to see this game
and it's in it's in its fullest form
this year when can we expect it
uh i don't we have not announced an
official release date
yet um you know we're really focused on
the quality and trying to create the
best experience we can
and in blizzard fashion you know we want
to make sure that it is ready for the
players by the time we release it and
get into their
into their hands absolutely all right
well morgan it's been a huge pleasure
thank you so much for joining me and
talking all about shadow lands
once again i'm current novena and for
anything shadowlands world of warcraft
coming up
come back here to gamespot thank you see
you later
[Music]
you